these are people who just have the
scientific and engineering discipline
but also that deep artistic
understanding and so they create new
things by arranging these differently in
this bag and when you see a design
that's done well it's beautiful it's a
beautiful thing you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen using
[Applause]
some of the world's leading architects
are people that you've probably never
heard of and they've designed and built
some of the world's most amazing
structures that you've probably never
seen or at least you don't think you
have one of these architects is dr. Doug
Berger distinguished engineer at
Microsoft Research next and if you use a
computer or store anything in the cloud
you're a beneficiary of the beautiful
architecture that he and people like him
work on every day today in a fast-paced
interview dr. Berger talks about how
advances in AI and deep machine learning
has placed new acceleration demands on
current hardware and computer
architecture offers some observations
about the demise of Moore's law and
shares his vision of what life might
look like in a post CPU post von Neumann
computing world that and much more on
this episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
Doug Berger welcome to the podcast today
thank you great to be here we're in for
an acronym rich recording session I
believe I assume that our audience knows
more about your world than I do
but since my mom listens I'm gonna
clarify a couple times I hope that's
okay with you
whether it's acronym heavy is TBD and
you are in SME you are actually a
distinguished engineer for MS our next
tell us what that is
the title is a standard Microsoft title
for somebody that is in a technology
leadership position MS our next is a
branch of MSR or organization within MSR
so when you think about MSR we have a
lot of diversity we have geographic
diversity we have disciplinary diversity
and we have some organizational
diversity and so next is just a
different organizational structure that
tends to produce different outcomes
that's how I'd like to think of it so
you do research in computer architecture
give our listeners an overview of the
problems you're trying to solve what
gets you up in the morning in computer
architecture research great question so
formally define computer architectures
define as the interface between hardware
and software and architecture is what
the software is able to see of the
hardware so if I build a chip and a
system and a disk drive and some memory
all of those things they're just dead
Hardware until you do something with
them and to do something with them you
have to have a way to talk to them and
so all of these things expose a way to
talk to them and that really is the
architecture you can think of it as the
language of the computer at its very
lowest level machine language machine
language right and how that translates
from people into the transistor that's
exactly right there's actually a lot of
layers in between the person and the
transistor and the architecture that I
just described is one of those layers
more towards the bottom but not at the
bottom right speaking of the stuff
that's at the bottom transistors and
devices and things like that we've
experienced a very long run of what we
called Moore's Law yes which wonderful
transistors get smaller but their power
density stays constant and some people
including you have suggested that
Moore's law is probably coming to an end
why do you think that is let me start
with a little bit of context and it's
heart all of this digital computing
we're doing is built up of switches and
wires it's a light switch you flick it
it turns on you flick it it turns off
that's really what a transistor is what
we do is we'd start with a wire and a
transistor which remember is just a
switch it's a fancy name for a switch
and then we'd start putting them
together and you put a few more
transistors together and then you have a
logic gate something they can say and or
not right take a zero and turn it into a
one that's a knot or two ones together
ANDed together become a 1 and a 1 and a
0 ANDed together becomes a zero just the
very basic universal logic functions
long ago and the time of Babbage we were
building computers that really didn't
work out of mechanical relays that we
had vacuum tubes which at least were
electronic and then of course the
transistor was invented and the
integrated circuit and these were a
really big deal because now it allowed
you to miniaturize these things on a
chip
sure and then what Gordon Moore did in
his seminal paper in the mid 60s he
pointed out that he expected these
things to double and density to be able
to fit twice as many of these things on
a chip on an integrated circuit in a
year and a half or two years as you
would to years ago and then he revised
the law in 1975 to be a little bit
faster and then we've been doubling the
density every couple years since then
for 50 years it's been a 50-year
exponential where the cost of computing
has been dropping exponentially for 50
years and that's what's giving us this
crazy Society we have with you know the
internet and computational science and
sequencing genomes are incredibly cheap
compared to what they were it's nuts
and so are we nearing the end of this
era so I get asked this a lot and
there's two versions of Moore's law
there's the actual and that he published
which talks about the rate at which
chips get denser and then there's what I
call the New York Times version which is
something loosely associated with an
exponential in computing right like
performance is growing exponentially
that's what we hear that's right that's
right that's what people think so now if
you were on the precise version which
that's where I am because that's my
field the rate of that density increase
has slowed down for the first time in 50
years so it hasn't stopped
but it's noticeably slowed now maybe the
ship manufacturers will pick the cadence
back up again and then I'll issue it may
a couple and say I was wrong but I think
we're in the endgame I think we're in a
period right now where it's slowed it
may be that we're on a new cadence
that's just slower or it may be that the
length of time between each new
generation of semiconductor technology
lengthens out and the problem really is
is that we're running up against atomic
limits I was just gonna say you've
defined these you know size limits in
terms of atoms right and how small they
are now if you have it again and half it
again we're pretty soon down to a couple
atoms I can't even comprehend how small
that is
yes now people have built single atom or
single electron transistors right so
it's not a question of can we it's more
question of can you build a chip that
has 10 billion of these on it
economically it's really a question of
economics because we know we can build
smaller devices but can you make them
work and sell them cheaply enough to
actually be worth doing the other thing
to note is that as we started to run
into atomic limits when we were scaling
down the transistors the old standard
very regular structure of a transistor
wasn't possible anymore I mean it used
to be a very simple thing that had you
know three bars of material with
something spray it on top and wires
connected to some of those terminals now
these things are actually very intricate
3d structures so they're just getting
more and more complex as we try to scale
them down of course that's to control
quantum tunneling of electrons so we're
not leaking a light when the switch is
off it should be off and there have been
challenges all along and we always find
interesting ways to deal with it and
people are doing incredibly creative
things now it's just getting really hard
I suspect even as you look at this
complexity of the transistors getting
smaller and smaller that you're looking
at other ways
you keep the progress and absolutely so
that's what I want to ask you next is
let's just assume that you're right and
what are you doing in a parallel
universe to keep the progress of
computing power and speed and efficiency
moving forward we're now in an uncertain
era where you know in one generation
your cost gains might be smaller than
expected or your power gains might be
smaller you might not get any speed and
you're trading these things off there's
still lots of advances going in the
other parts of computing things like
memory density flash memory network
speeds optics so there's all the
ancillary parts people are also working
on new types of computing trying to buck
it ties what some of these might be so
programmable biology is a super exciting
one right like DNA is a computer DNA is
a stored program that can actually
replicate itself yeah but there's a
program encoded in it and there's lots
of rules about it and so we're getting
actually better understanding those
programming languages they're more
statistical and that you're dealing with
you know stuff interacting in a
probabilistic way so that's a whole
different paradigm for computing the 50
years ago we didn't even know existed
and now we're actually starting to
leverage there's another one which you
could think of as just digital computing
that's not silicon based so people have
been looking at carbon nanotubes
different materials none of it looks
very close to me it looks like we're
kind of 10 years away from any of it
getting competitive and of course
silicon has had so much investment right
like you know hundreds of billions of
dollars if not trillions it takes you
know something that always worries me as
a researcher I know I'm jumping around a
little bit here is if you're on
technology ax and then there's
technology Y that is not only better but
will take you farther but if you don't
get Y started early enough X gets
advanced far enough that the amount of
money you need to bootstrap Y is just
too high it never happens absolutely
right and so that's gonna be really
interesting to see that play out when we
think about silicon and post silicon
technologies it may be that there are
magical much better things out there
that we'll never achieve because we've
invested too much in silicon and that
seems to be one of the drivers is the
cost of something I mean if you made a
compelling case for something and it was
too
would adopt it yep and so these
computing systems we have have become
exponentially cheaper for many decades
they're also very general mmm you know
they do everything and that's based on
something called von Neumann computing
right and that's a paradigm you know you
write software it's run on a CPU that's
kind of the paradigm we've been with for
a very long time and as the silicon
gains are slowing the gains you get from
that paradigm are also slowing and so
we're starting to see even the digital
computing ecosystem fracture and
diversify because of the huge economic
need to do more let me roll back a
minute and you get to the other bucket
so there's there's neural computing then
mm-hmm they are also a programmable
albeit learning machine and they're
incredibly interesting I mean just
profoundly interesting we don't really
understand how and why they work yet
despite all the progress we've made in
digital AI yeah there's something super
magical there that may not even be
understandable at the end of the day I
hope it will be we don't know and then
of course there's you know chemistry and
so there's just all these other ways to
compute mm-hmm and of course the nice
thing about the paradigm we've been on
is all of the levels are deterministic
you know exactly what they're capable of
what they can express is bounded but
very powerful sir Turing complete and if
you're a computer scientist and so it's
tractable and so you can each layer
hides the complexity underneath
presenting you with a relatively simple
interface that allows it to do all its
wonderful stuff and then now things are
getting more complex and interesting
yeah but also harder well and I as you
know a non-scientist here look at the
simplicity of the interface and the
underneath part is intimidating to me in
terms of trying to get my brain around
it but like you say when you unpack
what's in the box people go aha it's you
know I don't have to ignore that man
behind the curtain anymore that's right
I am that man behind anomaly that's
right yeah let me make a comment on that
these things are both incredibly simple
and incredibly complicated at the same
time but they've got
interfaces that are very clean and the
concepts are pretty simple like switch
and gate adder add two numbers binary
arithmetic right it's just math with
zeros and ones instead of zeros through
nines but then the number of things we
do to optimize the system it's insane
and the complexity of these things that
some of the most complex things humans
have ever built I mean you think about
five billion switches on one chip it's a
small postage stamp-sized thing with
five billion switches organized in a way
to make stuff go really fast I mean
that's amazing Simon Paton Jones said
that computers and software and
architecture are some of the most
amazing structures people have ever
built they are amazing structures and in
the architecture field when you're
designing one of those interfaces and
then deciding what you put in the chip
underneath to support that interface the
cool thing is it's unlike software where
it's much more open-ended I mean to me
when I write software I feel too free
there's no guardrails I could do
anything I had too much freedom and when
you're doing the hardware you have a
budget you have an area budget I have
this many square millimeters of silicon
yeah and you have to decide what to fill
it with and what the abstractions are
you exposed and how much to spend on
performance optimization versus features
if you want to put something else in you
have to take something out so your bag
is of a finite size and you're trying to
figure out how to fill up that bag with
the right components interconnected in
the right way to allow people to use it
for lots of stuff you want to be general
yeah you want to be efficient you want
it to be fast you want it to be simple
for software to use and so all of those
things you have to balance so it's
almost like an art rooted in science
there are a small number of people and
don't count myself among them who are
the true artists you know Jim Keller is
a very famous one who's active in the
area Bob Caldwell retired from Intel
Murray wiser also ferment I mean these
are some of the more recent examples but
these are people who just have the
scientific and engineering discipline
but also that deep artistic
understanding and so they create new
things by arranging these differently in
this bag and when you see a design
that's done well it's beautiful it's a
beautiful thing
[Music]
let's talk about a project that you
co-founded in : called project catapult
tell me about project catapult before I
moved to Microsoft I had started some
research with one of my PhD students
Hadi is my lazada who's a professor now
the University of California at San
Diego
and at the time the community was moving
towards multi-core and there was a not a
global consensus but definitely it was
the hot thing and people were saying if
we just figure out the way to write
parallel software we'll just scale up to
thousands of cores and Hadi and I really
I said this is you know when everyone's
buying it's time to sell right and so we
wrote a paper that ended up getting
published in 2011 and got some pretty
high visibility it didn't coin the term
dark silicon but it popularized it and
the observation was because the
transistors aren't getting more power
efficient we can keep increasing the
number of cores but we're not gonna be
able to power them so even if you have
parallel software and you drive up the
number of cores the benefits you get are
much lower than you've gotten
historically and what that really said
to me is that that's a great Avenue but
we're also gonna need something else and
so that something else started to be
specialized computing where you're
optimizing hardware for specific
workloads and the problem with that is
that building custom chips is expensive
and so what you didn't want is say a
cloud where people are renting computers
from us to have 47,000 different types
of chips and try to manage that and have
that be your strategy going forward and
so we took a bet on this hardware called
FPGAs now we're to your acronym soup it
stands for field programmable gate array
what they are is programmable hardware
so you do a hardware design and you
flash it on the FPGA chip that's why
they're called field programmable
because you can change them on the fly
in the field and as soon as you're done
using it you can change it to something
else you can actually change them every
few seconds so what we ended up doing
was to say let's take a big bet on this
technology and deploy it widely in our
cloud and we'll start lowering important
things into Hardware on that fabric
which is on a pretty interesting system
architecture too and then that's going
to be our general purpose
platform for hardware specialization and
then once you have hardware designs that
are being baked onto your FPGA is you
can take some of them or all of them and
then go spin those off into custom chips
when the economics are right so it's
sort of a way to dip your toe in the
water but also to get a very clean
homogeneous abstraction to get this
whole thing started and then while stuff
is evolving rapidly or if it's units are
too small you leave it on the
programmable fabric and if it becomes
super high scale so you want to optimize
the economics and/or it become super
stable and you might harden it to save
money in order to get more performance
so there's flexibility there that you
yeah the flexibility is a really key
thing and again the FPGA chips had been
used widely in Telecom
they're very good at processing streams
of data flowing through quickly and for
testing out chips that you were going to
build but in the cloud nobody had really
succeeded at deploying them at scale to
use not as a prototyping vehicle for
acceleration but as the actual
deployment vehicle well so what can you
do now post catapulter with catapult
that you couldn't do on a CPU or a GPU
well let me first say that the CPUs and
GPUs are amazing things that focus on
different types of workloads well the
CPUs are very general and what a CPU
actually does well is it takes a small
amount of data called the working set
sitting you know for those of you who
are architecture geeks now in its
registers and level 1 data cache and
then it streams instructions by them and
operating on those data we call that
temporal computing if the data that
those instructions are operating on is
too big or if those data are too big the
CPU doesn't actually work very well it's
not super efficient which is why for
example processing high bandwidth stream
coming off the network you need custom
chips like you know nix for that because
a CPU you know if it has to issue a
bunch of instructions to process each
byte and those bytes are coming in at 12
and a half billion bytes a second you
know that's a lot of it so what the GPUs
do well is something called Sindhi
parallelism which stands for single
instruction multiple data and the idea
there is you you have a bunch of tasks
that are the same all operating on
similar but not identical data
so you can issue one instruction and
that instruction ends up doing the same
operation on say eight data items in
parallel okay so that's the GPU model
and then the FPGAs are actually a
transpose of the CPU model
so rather than pinning a small amount of
data and running instructions through on
an FPGA we pin the instructions and then
run the data through interesting I call
that structural computing other people
have called it spatial I mean both terms
work but the idea is you take a
computational structure you know a graph
of operations and you pin it and you're
just flowing data through it
continuously and so the FPGAs are really
good for those sorts of workloads and so
in the cloud when we have functions that
can fit on a chip and you want to pin it
and stream data through at high rates it
works really well and it's a nice
complement to the CPUs okay so catapult
is catapult is our project code name for
Microsoft's large-scale deployment of
FPGA in the cloud sort of covers the
boards and the system architecture but
it's really a research project now I was
just gonna say is this now in research
is it beta is it production where are
you with it in late 2015 Microsoft
started shipping uh one of the catapult
FPGA boards and almost every new server
that it bought and that's being a sure
on other properties and so by this point
we've gone a very large scale this stuff
is deployed at ultra large scale
worldwide were one of the largest
consumers of FPGAs on the planet and so
of course there are now teams all over
the company that are using them to
enhance their own services when you are
a customer of using the accelerated
networking feature that speed that
you're getting which is a huge increase
in the speed both over what we had
before but also it's faster than any of
our competitors networks is because the
FPGA chip is actually rewriting the
network flows with all of the policies
that we have to keep our customers
secure and keep the virtual private
networks private and make sure that
everyone adheres to our policies and so
it's inspecting the packets as they're
flowing by at 50 gigabits fifty billion
bits a second and then rewriting them to
follow our rules and making sure that
they obey the rules if you try to do
that on the CPUs which is where reader
or the CPUs are very general they're
programmable they do a good job but you
use a lot of them right to process flows
at that rate and so the FPGAs are just a
better alignment for that computational
Moll talk about brain wave project brain
wave so brain wave there's a big move
towards AI now as I think you know just
about everyone listening will know very
hot area and in particular it was
spurred by this thing called deep
learning which I think many of your
listeners will know too but what they
figured out was that with the deep
models you know deep neural networks if
you add more data to train them they get
better as you add more data you make
them bigger and they get better and they
kind of march through a lot of the
traditional AI spaces like machine
translation speech understanding
knowledge encoding computer vision and
in replacing each dedicated set of
algorithms for that domain that had been
developed painstakingly over years and
that's really what spurred I think a lot
of this huge movement because the same
thing okay there's something here these
things are very general and if we can
just make them bigger and train more and
more data we can do even more
interesting things which has largely
been borne out it's really interesting
and so of course that put a lot of
pressure on the silic and given the
trends that we were discussing and so
now there's a big investment in custom
architectures for AI machine learning
and specifically deep learning and so
brainwave is the architecture that we
built in my team working with partners
in Bing and partners in Azure to deploy
to accelerate Microsoft services right
so sort of our version of a deep neural
network processor what some people call
a neural processing unit or ndu and so
for an organization like Bing who's
really compute bound like they're trying
to learn more and more they can give you
better answers better quality searches
show you what you need to see and so
we've been able to deploy larger models
now that run in the small amount of time
that you're allowed to take before you
have to return an answer to a user and
so we've been running it at worldwide
scale for some time now and now when we
announced it build is that we're
bringing it to a sure
or our customers to use and also a
private preview where customers in their
own servers in their companies can
actually buy one of our boards and with
the catapult architecture and then pull
models down AI models down from Azure
and run them on their own site as well
Wow
so they become an azure endpoint in some
sense that benefits from all of the AI
that's sitting in Azure one other thing
about the brainwave stack itself that's
significant is that I think right now
for inference which is asking of the
questions a lot of the other
technologies use something called
batching where you have to glom say 64
different little quests together and
ship them as a package and then you get
all the answers back at once the analogy
I like to use is you're standing in a
bank line and you're the second person
but there's a hundred people in line
that the teller processes them all by
taking all their IDs and then asking
them all what they want and then you
know withdrawing all the money and then
handing it deeper and you all finish at
the same time
right that's batching I love it it's
great for throughput on these machines
but not so good for latency so we're
really pushing this real-time a high
angle that leads me to a kind of
philosophical question how fast is fast
enough well how fast is fast enough
really depends on what you're trying to
do so for example if you are taking
multiple signals from around the web and
trying to figure out that for example
there's an emergency somewhere a couple
minutes might be fast enough you know a
millisecond is not life and death if
you're doing interactive speech with
somebody actually very small pauses
matter for the quality of the experience
we've all experienced that in you know
watching a television interview where
there's latency between the exact and
you often step on each other that's
right another good example Micra nother
piece of AI tech that Microsoft unveiled
was it's hpu which goes in the hololens
headset oh and that's also processing
neural networks that was a you know very
very amazing team in a different
organization in the Hollande's
organization that built that chip I'm
working with a LAN spill Andrews team
but that chip if you think about the
latency requirements it's figuring out
the environment around you so that it
can hang virtual content that's stable
as your eyes are darting around
so you know even a couple milliseconds
there is a problem so really how fast
depends on like what you're trying to do
yeah yeah so speed is one component and
the other is cost yeah you know so if
you have billions of images or millions
of lines of text and you want to go
through and process it so that you can
you know understand the questions that
people commonly ask you know in your
company or you want to look for you know
signs that this might be cancer and a
bunch of radiological scans then what
really matters there is cost to serve so
you have sort of a trade-off between how
fast is it how much processing power
you're gonna throw at it right away and
how cheap is it to do one right request
and the great thing about the brainwave
system is I think we're actually in a
really good position on both I think
we're the fastest and we are in the
ballpark to be the cheapest what was
your path to Microsoft research how did
you end up here I was a professor at the
University of Texas for 10 years I
worked very closely with the gentleman
named Steve Kepler who we were sort of -
in a box and we did this really fun and
ambitious project that was called trips
where we decided we wanted to build a
better type of CPU and I mean I this the
catapult was my first fpga project so I
I'm really actually a hardened chip guy
and so we came up with some ideas and
said hey there's a better way to do CPUs
and it's a really a new architecture you
know a new interface to the machine that
uses different principles than the
historical ones and so we raised a whole
bunch of DARPA money that DARPA was
super interested in the technology built
a team in the university went through
the grind built a working chip I mean
Steve was a expert in that space he
really loved the design of the chip did
a phenomenal job we worked together in
the architecture and the compiler so we
built this full working system boards
chips compilers operating system all
based on these very new principles and
academically it was a pretty influential
project and pretty high profile but we
got to the end of that it was too
radical to push into industry it was too
expensive to push into a startup you
know semiconductor starts weren't hot at
the time but after that I really wanted
to go and try to influence things more
directly
and so Microsoft came calling right
around the time I was wondering what's
an accident that just seemed like time
for new challenges so your work has
amazing potential and that usually means
we need to be thinking about both the
potential for good and the potential for
not-so-good so is there anything about
what you're doing that keeps you up at
night I'll tell you that I don't worry
about the AI apocalypse at all I think
we're still tens or hundreds of
thousands of times away from the
efficiency of a biological system and
these things are really not very smart
yes we need to keep an eye on it and
ethics I mean frankly I worry more about
global warming and climate change that's
kind of my big figma night that keeps me
up at night so that's the extent that
our work makes computing more efficient
and we can help solve big important
scientific problems then that's great so
as we close what's the most exciting
challenge or set of challenges that you
see may be on the horizon for people
that are thinking of getting into
research in hardware systems and
computer architecture really it's find a
North Star that you passionately believe
in and then just drive to it
relentlessly everything else takes care
of itself and you know find that passion
don't worry about the career tactics and
you know which job should you take find
the job that puts you on that path to
something that you really think is
transformational okay so what might be
one of those transformational and goals
for me and this is I think the first
time I've talked about it I think we're
beginning to figure out that there is
something more profound waiting out
there than all of these heterogeneous
accelerators for the post von Neumann
age so we're at the end of Moore's Law
we're kind of in the silicon endgame and
von Neumann computing meaning you know
these the stream of instructions I
described you know has been with us
since von no I mean invented it you know
in the in the 40s and it's been
amazingly successful but right now we
have von Neumann computing and then a
bunch of bolted on accelerators and then
kind of a mess with people exploring
stuff I think there's a deeper truth
there for that next phase which in my
head I'm calling structural computation
so that's what I'm thinking about a lot
now I'm starting to sniff out that I
think there is something there that
might be general and be that next
big leap in computer architecture and of
course the exciting thing is I could be
totally wrong and it's it's just a mess
but that's the fun of it
Doug Berger I wish I had more time with
you thanks for coming in and sharing the
depth of knowledge that you've got
stacked in that brain my pleasure thank
you for the great questions and for all
your listeners to learn more about dr.
Doug Berger and the latest research on
acceleration architecture for the
next-generation hyper scale clouds visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]